thank you to the organizers shresh
jeanette
monge
marco for hosting me you know i'm really
excited to come here in person
i come from pittsburgh all the way here
to just give this talk and meet all of
you
um
so yeah as janet mentioned i'm sanjivan
i am currently a research scientist at
aurora where we do self-driving which
i'll talk about today i'm also joining
cornell assistant professor in july 2022
so if you're a prospective student reach
out
today i'm really excited to talk about
interactive imitation learning
sort of how do we build robots that
learn from human interaction and plan
alongside humans
and in the spirit of this lecture if you
have any questions this is please uh
this is an interactive session so
please please feel free to ask
right so let's get started
so the question at the core of my
research is how do we design robots that
both understand and learn from natural
human interactions you know for those
who have seen this movie baymax
this will be a familiar scene where hero
teaches baymax to do a fist bump
you know what's beautiful about the
scene is that hero through a simple
sequence of interactions
is able to communicate this novel
concept of a fist bump
to baymax right so how do we build such
robots that continually improve
and learn online
to adapt to individual human preferences
now to do so i think we need to solve
two fundamental challenges
first
how should robots learn from natural
human interactions you know consider
this case where your grandma receives a
brand new robot apprentice you know
there are a number of tasks she wants
the apprentice to do in a specific way
but that's latent in her mind right how
can the robot interact with her to infer
these latent preferences from natural
modes of feedback like gestures
interventions or corrections
second how should robots plan alongside
human partners to accomplish these tasks
you know the robot must be able to
anticipate how humans respond to their
emotions uh understand their intent and
move in a safe predictable manner
okay
so for the past two and a half years
i've been working um in self-driving at
aurora with an amazing team led by
drewbag now
you know our key product is the aurora
driver this is a
general suit of software that's designed
to work on any vehicle from passenger
sedans to class 8 trucks
now
you may be wondering what does this hunk
of steel have to do with humans
right the answer is actually a lot
let me show you
so this is a hyperlapse of the aurora
driver hauling goods in texas without
any human interventions
it's really fascinating to see this
robot
drive like a human alongside
other humans in the road
in the real world engaging in novel
interactions like merges lane changes
stop signs unprotected left turns and
much more
and keep in mind these are negotiations
that the robot is doing with real humans
in the real world
now this is not a one-off result our
product is hauling goods for fedex every
day
um it's pretty cool that in just nine
months we went from
never driving on a truck to this result
so
what is the science behind this result
right that is what i'm here to talk
about
well let's begin by looking at any one
snapshot and ask what is the optimal
action that the robot can do in a
situation
now
you might think like myself in the
beginning why not just take the official
driving handbook
and apply that right
well that would not be very useful
because most of the rules of driving
aren't explicit
but rather implicit
you know this orchestrated chaos that
you see is what i call traffic back home
it's uh absolutely unclear to me if i
can design a robot that can engineer a
set of rules to
get repeat this feat
um and that sort of leads to one of the
first
messages which is explicitly programming
such rules is tedious for instance in
self-driving the
right rule depends very much on what
other humans are doing but interestingly
we humans every day on the road
are able to drive so
implicitly programming robots by
imitating human driving
seems like a right strategy so that's
one of the key pieces that i'll talk
about
the second piece is that robots are not
alone in the road
take a look at this busy unprotected
left it's full of pedestrians and cars
if the robot views these pedestrians
simply as dynamic obstacles that it must
avoid it can never make that turn
right it has to actively create an
opening by negotiating with
other actors and and predicting how they
will respond
so to do this the robot has to
understand the latent intent of other
human actors and communicate
their own intent to them right
okay to to make things a little bit
concrete let's quickly ground these
problems in a more familiar and general
framework of a markov decision process
so to recall
an mdp is how we formalize sequential
decision making so you have you know
state actions
or rewards or as i like to think costs
and transitions
so the state here is the position and
velocity not just of the robot
but of every other human actor in the
road
and
the
the important thing is that the cost
function or the reward function it's
latent we don't know what what the
reward function is and we know some
parts of it but we don't know it in
general
um and we need to use imitation learning
to recover this cost function that makes
the robot drive like a human
also the transition function is unknown
because it depends on how the state of
the world of other humans evolve
based on actions the robot takes
so we need to learn this function as
well by predicting latent human intent
okay so
yes um
yes
so maybe why do you want to imitate
humans humans can be pretty bad drivers
right
yeah that's a great question so when i
in this talk when i talk about imitating
humans i talk about imitating our expert
human
drivers who are you know
trained um specialists who are driving
the car on the road and perhaps that is
a practical decision that we make in the
industry that you know
the drivers literally determine the
product uh so the so you know
they're they're trained specialists they
know how to drive a truck we just want
our product to drive like them and they
know when their driving is not good so
they're able to
curate out those bad demonstrations but
yeah in the real world it's a great
question we've probably come to that at
the end
when humans are not experts
it becomes a bit more tricky
great question
um anymore
all right let's let's keep going so
yeah so with that let's return back to
the original picture
so today we'll talk about
two challenges um
first we'll talk about imitation
learning so how do we interact with the
human to learn the optimal policy
and
second we'll talk about intent
prediction how do we interactively
forecast
human actions conditioned on
the actions that the robot takes
okay so let's begin with the first
challenge of imitation learning
so i'll begin with a really simple
problem that's actually inspired by real
world events at aurora
so
let's say you want to learn how to lane
change right so
on the left is our truck and on the
right we have two cars
and there's a slot between the cars
and the oh general idea is that you want
to extract features that describe the
role to describe the scene
and you want to learn a function that
says should we lane change or not right
so it's like a straight up binary
classification so it should be pretty
easy
let's think a little bit about the
features
you know you might have
what is the distance to the exit right
um
is there a disabled vehicle on the
shoulder
how does traffic congestion look in the
lanes these are some of the features
that you might have
now it turns out one day one of your
interns come in and says you know what
let's also add a feature that stores the
decision we made at the previous time
step because i think that's going to be
a very useful feature you said why not
let's let's add that as as well so you
add in the past action right whether you
lane changed or not in the previous
cycle
so a standard approach to imitation
learning is called behavior cloning
which basically treats the problem as a
supervised learning problem
there are three simple steps first
go collect lots of data of humans lane
changing so
sometimes in some cases you see that the
humans don't change a lane because maybe
the the the right lane is blocked and
sometimes you see that they take a lane
opening and you go collect this data
you train a classifier that maps
features to decisions against a binary
classification problem
and then you validate this policy on
some held out data and if it looks good
deploy right
so you get an exciting slack message
from your intern one night oh my god
this classifier is amazing it's got 99
accuracy and before you say overfitting
i added regularization so we're good to
go
right so you're stunned the
intern is overjoyed the team goes out
for beers right
next day you test this model
you think wow 99 this is going to be a
great model
so
let's say the truck
is next to a car and decides to lane
change and you find that a bit odd
because seems like this actor is very
close seems like a tight lane change but
whatever it's 99 it's good
so the truck begins a lane change but
the after doesn't slow down they're
still going
at a high speed right
um
and strangely your product doesn't abort
the lane change it just keeps going
right
um
eventually it
it almost runs the actor off the road
right
what happened
why didn't the the learner just simply
abort the lane change when it looked
dangerous can anybody take a guess
[Music]
a no yeah than
the fact that they were going to do it
and then they decided not yeah
excellent right
should have had you in our team um
yeah that's exactly correct so let me
let's try to break down so the answer
was um
i should repeat this so the answer was
that
in the data the humans never uh
showed a recovery they either made that
made up their mind and never did the
lane change or they just did it
um so just to dig into that a little bit
um
if you looked at a training data again
you see these two clusters it's either
don't change don't change don't change
data no no no no or yes you see yes
right
and what that cr that creates this sort
of strong correlation between
the past action and the action at the
current timestamp
and before you think this is a bug this
is not a book
humans drive smoothly of course the past
is correlated to the current action
right
um
so
other than the rare transition points
most of the data that you collect have
this sort of strong correlation between
two consecutive time steps
okay that's fine but then what happens
at test time
the robot just makes one mistake at the
beginning
but once it begins to go
it latches on to that mistake and
continues going
this is what we call feedback
right we have this bad feedback loop
and what feedback does it forces the
robot into states that it has not seen a
train time so
since there's no label for the state the
robot doesn't know how to recover it's
never seen a state where you know it's
doing a lane change and things have gone
bad right the humans never entered that
situation for whatever reason
and so
feedback drives a
shift between the training distribution
right where the human never made the
mistake
and a test distribution
where are the robots clearly making
mistakes in getting into these
situations
we call this a covariate shift shift in
the input
right
and
um theory shows that this leads to
compounding errors on mathematically
known as
o epsilon t square errors that grows
quadratically in time
so
feedback drives covariate shift this is
the
fundamental challenge that
differentiates imitation learning from
mere supervised learning
and more concretely if feedback breaks
an assumption in machine learning that
data is id
in fact the data here depends on your
learner your learner induces the state
distribution it visits
questions
okay cool um
now in case you're wondering how common
is this problem sounds made up
let me assure you
it is a problem so these are just
four papers from self-driving uh
companies
and academia from the last few years
that talk about this very issue
and it's not just the self-driving
industry so back in my post-op days at
udab
we built a whole fleet of self-driving
cars called musher so this is a video of
these cars driving around the hallways
and we were trying to program these
these cars ground up from imitation
learning
um so on the top right is jonathan
spencer who was driving around these
cars providing demonstrations
on the bottom you see a visualization of
this loan policy where blue are good
actions and red are bad
okay so
when we roll the learner out it looks
like it's doing a good job until it
crashes into the wall right
it's the same underlying issue it makes
a mistake enters a state that looks like
i'm driving straight first into a wall
and oops i haven't seen the state before
i'm going to continue you know going
straight and crashing to the wall right
so i'm going to continue making mistakes
um
okay so
there seems to be a mountain of evidence
for feedback driving covariate shift
so we thought
probably this should be reproducible in
standard benchmarks that we use in
academia right
turns out we are totally wrong
so we took
benchmarks from imitation learning
papers simply ran behavior cloning for
long enough to drive down optimization
errors
and the loan policy turned out to be
pretty good
the performance values were very close
to the expert
so we thought okay maybe these
environments are too easy
let's try more complex environments
turns out literature has time and time
again showed behavior cloning does
pretty well
in fact i think there's a recent paper
by florence at all that shows behavior
cloning on these
deep d4 rl date benchmarks is pretty
comparable to most alternatives not the
best but it's pretty good
um
so this was puzzling right
just convinced you feedback is a real
problem in self-driving and our
competitors have reported it
but on standard benchmarks behavior
cloning just seems to be fine
so
what is the explanation is it to do with
the data
is it to do with the problem is it to do
with the policy
or something else is going on
so in times like this we need clarity
and
what better way to get clarity than to
think about the infinite data limit well
you know to to take one part of the
equation out of it
so
we're going to take a slight detour
we're going to i'm going to convince you
that covariate shift isn't just one
thing it's actually three regimes
some are easy some are hard and some are
just right
okay
right
so let's start with the easy setting
here the human expert is realizable so
with infinite data you can make the
error zero
for example let's say you have a race
car and you put it on a track
you see that the expert drives perfectly
down the center of the track
right and so shown on the left is the
say the distribution that the expert
induces
and if you have infinite data your
learner is just going to exactly drive
down loss to zero so you're going to see
the two distributions match exactly
and so the solution for whenever you're
in this regime the solution is simple
just go get lots of data
and
if you do behavior cloning life is good
and you're in your policy matches the
expert and we conjecture that
men that you know this might be the
explanation that many of the benchmarks
um simply fall into this easy regime
because the expert is either realizable
or your network is expressive enough
that it's able to explain the data well
enough
now
what if the learner
is not
the expert is not realizable
it and the expert doesn't visit all the
states for instance
let's say our learner for whatever
reason can't perfectly drive this down
the center of this track
okay
once the learner spins out of the track
it doesn't know what to do it's never
seen how to recover so it's going to
keep making mistakes
um
good analogy
from uh from from drew is you know think
of the expert as roadrunner and the
learner as wiley curry
if the expert never fell off a cliff
how will the learner know how to get
back on right
and this is precisely the flavor of the
problems that we saw
you know the human is
was for whatever reason not realizable
and we didn't visit all the states
we call this the hard setting
right
so in a seminal paper ross and back now
showed that in this setting
you behavior cloning has no hope
it's never it's it's going to hit this
worst case or epsilon t square error
um recently our work uh kind of
generalized this result with this is
work with goku swami that showed that
entire class of off policy methods so
you know methods where all you have is
um you know
just a bunch of data and you have no
interactive expert your you kind this is
the best you can do
so you might be wondering okay when does
this setting occur
um one one uh signature of this setting
is whenever the expert
has access to more privileged
information so
very quickly
this is true in self-driving because the
human often
has um has more context than perception
can detect right maybe they can look at
a scene and tell when a driver is
signaling them to go and our just
perception hasn't caught up to it yet
that's that's one place where it happens
another setting is when you're imitating
algorithms that are clairvoyant
right think of an um you're imitating an
algorithm that has access to more
information the full model
and you simply can't do exactly what the
algorithm did so i had a string of
papers in my phd that
really try to analyze this problem and
understand the consequences of this
information gap so this is this is
another setting
finally there's this recent paper from
deepmind
that talks about language sequence
models uh like chatbots
and shows that they too can fall into
this category
where they create loops of self-delusion
because their actions feed back into
their
next state and so on
so the heart setting is a very real
inescapable setting
and and we need to deal with it
okay questions
so is it practical to like include in
the training data like situations where
your like expert makes mistakes but
corrects yeah it's a great question i'll
actually come to that um in the big in
the end um
and and there'll be a setting in the
middle where we'll do that but for now
let's assume that
you know that's not the case
that uh the expert hasn't it has limited
expert support so hasn't really made all
this mistakes but yeah great question
anymore
cool okay let's keep going uh so yeah
okay great there's a hard setting what
can we do here
um fortunately there's a solution and
we've known this for a long time now
which is you have to interactively query
the expert
so
a very high level in a seminal paper
rossital
showed a very simple meta algorithm
called dagger
which iterates over three simple steps
roll out your current learner
go ask the human what the right action
is wherever the learner visits
take this data aggregate it and trained
the learner on the on the full data
and
if you do this these this this three
steps over and over again
eventually the process stabilizes
and you kind of recover a policy that's
pretty good that has the best achievable
box of obsolete
and um you know recently we have
generalized this setting and you know we
just we realized dagger is just one
algorithm in the entire class of
algorithms and this entire class of
algorithms
for example algorithms like aggravate
also fall into the setting they all
enjoy this observant guarantee and they
all look like you know take your current
learner go roll it out go ask the human
what
what to do in the state and go
add this data to your data set
okay
so if you're in the heart setting
you're out of luck you need an
interactive expert you need to
interactively ask the human hey
i'm in trouble what should i have done
in this situation
right
but
is this really practical like
to ask the human over and over to label
situations that the robot visits think
back to when we were all learning to
drive
um imagine you are doing all sorts of
crazy things like going down the wrong
side of the highway and asking your
driving instructor
please help me um that was going to be a
very that's going to be a very
petrifying experience for your
instructor
and this is this is a real problem like
it's unsafe for humans especially to
give feedback to states for robot visits
and it's impractical
instead how can we learn from more
natural
human interactions
let's say interventions
um
so let's quickly try to think about how
interventions work right
reconjecture that
let's say humans have a mental model of
a subspace of states that is good enough
right
as long as the robot is in this state
the human doesn't feel the need to
correct
as the robot is about to leave the
subspace the human intervenes and drives
the robot back into this region and
gives back control
okay that's the high level idea how do
we turn this into a mathematical
algorithm
for the learner to learn
um
we had a very simple insight which is
an intervention is telling us something
about the human's latent value function
um
what do i mean by that
presumably
presumably in their mind somewhere
humans have a latent value function that
captures the cumulative cost of taking
actions and acting optimally thereafter
right
every piece of intervention gives us a
tiny glimpse of this value function it's
basically saying
is a state good or state is a state
action good or state action bad
um
and even non-interventions the fact that
they're not intervening is telling us
something that the robots probably know
in a good enough state
so we have a very simple approach called
expert intervention learning or eel that
exploits this insight
so the way ul works is
we are going to model interventions as
constraints on the latent action value
right
so let's formalize this very briefly
let's say we are solving for an action
value q
that map state action to
real values so the lower the value
function the better
given a set of expert demonstrations s
star and a star
sample from p of expert
the objective is to correctly classify
these demonstrations for example a star
must be
belong to the minimum of q the action
human takes must be the optimal action
next as the robot executes the policy
we're going to end up with three types
of constraints
stage one when the human is not
intervening
we can definitively say that the q
values are below some threshold delta
right
stage two when the human takes over
something bad happened right so at least
for that state action that had to be
above above this threshold delta
um and finally as the human is
recovering
um
they're acting locally in a locally
optimal way
so
you can you can specify that's the third
constraint and you put them all together
and you end up with this sort of
constraint optimization problem
such that um and which you can solve
very efficiently in an online
uh way to get
a regret bound of epsilon t so this is
as good as what dagger would have given
you so this is as good as
if the human had shown you corrections
you could have also
um
you would have the same bound right
questions
okay cool um
yeah um so
in order to implement this expert
intervention learning at what do you
actually have would you do you think for
implementation of it you actually have
people who are monitoring the state of
the robot or does the robot have to
self-identify when it hits this
threshold that it's no longer within
uh say its action here is less than this
delta good that you've
stated here okay that's a great question
the question was uh is a human
monitoring the robot and saying um you
know whether the threshold was crossed
or not as a robot self-reporting
um for the for in this work
the human is intervening so the humans
monitoring um whenever the human
intervenes that act of their
intervention we
we called that time point
when the threat when the q value went
above the threshold right
um
but but but your question i take your
question that
can can we actually think about robots
self-reporting when they think they've
hit an anomalous situation i think
that's a it's an interesting question um
and and
and there's some work that tries to uh
you know
essentially have a robot self-report
when it when it hit a normal situation
ship that data to the human and ask them
to give feedback here was this bad or
not
but uh but in this work we are not doing
that here we are having an a humans
explicitly intervening
cool
okay i have a
yeah so in this case in this work uh the
agent action value function was
um simply a two-layer mlp that's that's
trying to map state actions to values
um there's some work that when we
extended this work to
settings where you kind of
are trying to learn cost functions there
then this q value is parameterized as
the per time step cost function where
and and your and and then you can kind
of approximate the q value by summing
over the costs uh summing up the cost
over roll outs right
so
um so yeah that that's how we kind of
parameterize q
anyway
cool okay awesome
so
uh how does this does this work uh how
does eel do perform on the robot
well so here you can see jonathan uh
kind of intervening as soon as the robot
gets close to the wall and then
returning back control so
you know he's he's continually doing
this and in the early trials eel is just
like behavior cloning
because of compounding errors it it you
know it keeps failing but
as
more and more interven as it gets more
and more intervention it starts to get
better and better and just after 60
seconds of trials
eel runs without any intervention at all
which which is pretty cool compared to
you know how much time
you know how much effort dagger would
have taken
and and yeah on this particular setting
um
behavior cloning failed even after 24
demonstrations
um so just a very quick quantity look at
quantitative plots right you can see eel
is able to drive down errors with much
less queries
waver cloning plateaus as we explained
and dagger wastes a lot of
repeated effort
by acquiring humans in obviously good
states
and the closest baseline was this
algorithm called a g dagger which is
like eel
except it only uses explicit feedback
it's not using this implicit feedback of
no interventions means something good is
happening
so
we showed both practically and
theoretically that's this is throwing
away some crucial information so the way
i like to think about this is eel is
trying to squeeze out as much juice as
it can
from the intervention signal
right
um
okay
cool so
so in the heart setting um
you know
we were able to get around this problem
of non-realizable expert but we required
an interactive expert that we had to
query on policy
but um very briefly we are going to talk
about a setting in the middle and this
is in relation to the question that was
asked earlier
so
what if you still had a non-realizable
expert but
one that was full support right
so the expert visits all the states
now
even in this setting behavior cloning is
pretty bad like it's um you know it
because uh there's still compounding of
errors
but
you don't need an interactive human
expert
in this setting
instead
you can get by with an interactive
simulator
and and
just with an interactive simulator you
can kind of hit o epsilon t error right
yes maybe you're going to answer this
yeah but similar to really doesn't align
well with the real world is that kind of
the medium set up that you're talking
about yeah that's a you're advanced here
um
we're in a company so we can we have
money we can make simulators um the
jeanette's asking a good question which
is when the real world no one gives you
a simulator i will maybe uh
yeah maybe not touch it on this wait are
you claiming aurora as a simulator that
is as good as the real world riding
experience on an american highway
it's good enough for what we're going to
do okay but uh not not like it has to be
good enough as we'll see good enough for
the algorithm bounce to sort of work um
so yeah good enough simulator let's put
it with an epsilon yeah in the robot
example the video what was the input to
the policy was it like a very high
dimension
just yeah i'd mention image compress so
just like an overhead image of like the
occupancy map just so and then that's
kind of compressed so the action space
is a
set of primitives that it can take and
the input space is just a snapshot of
like its local map
can you explain again why eil also
performs staggered as much yeah so the
the outperform thing
is with caveats it's how many times ill
queries the human
versus how many times dagger requires
the human to get with an epsilon
performance block
so
yeah so the the idea is eel is um
okay good the idea is um dagger is
question querying the human even in
states where
you know there's it has a lot of labels
right because the dragon algorithm
naively written
just says roll out the learner on all
states go query the human
eel is simply getting interventions
it's getting queries whenever the human
whenever the robot makes a mistake
so
it's like imagine there's a bubble every
time the robot leaves the bubble it's
only then is the human giving queries
you're not you're not filling in
you're not carrying the human inside the
bubble right whereas dagger squaring the
human wear with the robot so that sort
of difference
okay good quick question yes
um how does eel compare with like rough
and not referenced and ranking based
policy like when you compare it to like
okay this is a better policy than
something that was previously seen
ranking based in that sense because
you're also like it seems like it's been
running like it reduces the house and
half's basically strength
yeah i would say that um
if you had a ranking-based approach
that's trying different policies if we
didn't actually compare eel to you know
show
preference-based methods showing two
different policies and asking the human
for feedback i would say that
um
you know um
[Music]
i mean it's it's kind of difficult to
compare these two approaches because eel
something that's running on policy
whereas
you could in theory be
super smart about
exactly what two queries you choose to
query the human to collapse uncertainty
in an efficient way but there are other
challenges for example you know um
it you know
you would have you would have to make
assumptions about
the you know how to choose two two
policies so you you reduce entropy so we
didn't really compare with with the
preference-based methods but i think
that's an interesting uh avenue to
explore
cool
okay sounds good so
i'm just going to blaze through this
setting um it's a very high level
so the setting again is a medium setting
and we've been thinking about this for a
while now and the underlying idea is
that
you can use an interactive simulator to
build
the distribution that the learner visits
that's the high level idea so in this
setting the expert gives you a bunch of
demonstration and then just walks away
by using the simulator
you're building
um
the distribution the learner induces and
the goal is to simply you know match
these two distributions
and
you know you can think of that them as
specific specifically matching
performance metrics uh performance
moments to get an oh epsilon t guarantee
that's the high level idea so
um
you know
interestingly there is an entire
spectrum of
moment matching algorithms in this
setting that i'm not going to be able to
go into details today but
you know on the right hand side you have
algorithms
that match what we call reward moments
so
you're trying to find a reward function
that discriminates between the learner
and the expert
um
all inverse reward learning algorithms
fall into this setting um you know max
and irl gail we have our own algorithm a
drill that minimizes ipm metrics all
fall into the setting
the catch is it's not talked about but
you need an india planning oracle that's
able to explore
all possible actions so this exponential
space to to figure out how to match
trajectories with the with the human so
that that's a catch
on the left you have matching value
moments so
the idea is you're trying to find a
value function
that discriminates between the
expert and the learner
and we have an algorithm alice that
essentially does this but
you know the trick is you have to adjust
for covariate shift
and you can you can do that by
re-weighting data using density ratio
methods
and
so
you know you don't need to do planning
for alice but you need lots and lots of
samples
to estimate the density ratio perfectly
and there's a whole
set of things you can do in the middle
where you can try to mix and match these
methods so you can do k steps of
planning
and then density ratio your terminal
state
to
essentially get the robot to visit a set
of just states that look a lot like the
humans
right
the nice thing is all of these
algorithms
guarantee this o epsilon t which is in
some sense the best you could do
um but you know depending on
you know depending on how much you want
how much samples you have versus
um how much time you want to spend with
your planning oracle you can choose some
setting in the middle
yeah
so the planning article is uh if any
inverse reward learning
method
needs a planner given a reward function
it needs to
find the optimal policy right so you
need to call a planner that searches
over all possible actions to give you
the optimal policy so that's what we've
got it's not in like the generative
setting like not in the gale setting
like in the policy well you can say gail
is
running policy gradients right but um
you know you can come up and i mean
ultimately you can create mdps where it
has to visit every action of every state
to actually find the optimal policy
right given a reward function and that's
kind of hidden but that's a that's a
real price that you pay
um when you use this method
okay um any more questions
cool
um all right so we could move on to the
second half so yeah you know we that
sort of completes our story
you know we talked about this three
regimes of covariate shift easy medium
and hard but the easy setting just go to
behavior cloning but the hard setting
you need to you need an interactive
expert but the interesting setting is a
medium there's a lot of research in this
setting
if you have a simulator if you can
somehow if you have a dynamics model
imperfect ones as well
you have some hope of you know not
querying an expert online but still
trying to estimate your uh distribution
yeah so i guess following on the um
question if you have say like a driving
simulator that has good models of say
how the other vehicles are going to
respond right which would be something
you need to have a good driving
simulator why wouldn't you just use that
for like online planning or something
like this that's a great question um
i think um
you know there's
you can ask there's two different
requirements of a good simulator to do
you know implement these kind of methods
and something that's going to drive your
car on the road you know there's safety
uh verification
um constraints when you're actually
deploying the product on the road which
you may be okay with in the simulator it
doesn't have to do doesn't have to get
the crazy edge cases correct but maybe
your product has to
and so i think those two kind of
separate
yes
uh can the simulator model human intent
yeah uh the simulator can i mean
uh it it can it can it can because you
know
um
so i'm assuming by human intent you mean
whether the humans trying to like lane
change or not or go ahead or not yeah so
the simulators that we use are we call
them smart actors and they can
they can kind of model human intent to
respond to things that the human does to
to what the robot does right
let's say a car of like avoid things
worked into then why not just use the
what's the algorithm being used
to simulate the
the simulator kind of has a bit of an
advantage it kind of knows it's created
the setting so when someone creates a
simulation the simulation sort of knows
the scenario knows the context and so
it's actually pretty
it's contrived enough where the
simulator can actually um you know has
access to
a lot of lot more information um to you
know create intelligent actors but it's
quite different when you're
when you're out in the real world and
you don't know what setting you're
actually in don't know that you're in a
contested merge or contested lane change
right so then it can get kind of tricky
so interest of time i'm just going to
accelerate
um to the second half of the talk
so yeah i think this set of videos
videos just show that you know this this
the things we talked about today runs in
the real world so you have um you know
we have on-road interventions that are
then turned into simulations that then
the model uses to make better models and
just it works
and yeah i mean just quickly to touch on
open questions there are a lot of open
questions especially in the medium
setting
for example you know you're looking
theoretically at what are minimax
optimal algorithms
we are looking at something that's
become increasingly important which is
the role of confounds in the data
you know
human has a lot of unobserved variables
that influence their actions and so
you know how do you do imitation
learning under confounds and
there was a question earlier about
what if your experts aren't optimal what
if they're suboptimal
so um these you know
all three of these problems are pretty
interesting and
and uh we were kind of uh thinking about
them
but yeah uh an interest of time let's
talk about the second half of the talk
which will be shorter
um
that's about the second half is about
intent prediction which is how do we
interactively forecast human action so
we talked a little bit about intent
uh we're going to formalize this in in
this in the second half
okay so like we did before let's start
with a simple example
uh that i really like by the way uh
merges so when we all learn how to drive
this is a very stressful thing merging
for the first time
um how does a robot um
so how does a robot kind of negotiate a
merge right so we have a robot truck in
the right of way lane and we have a car
that's merging in
and
let's say we've already solved
limitation learning so we already have a
good cost function by imitation learning
now we have to plan with this robot we
need to
so to do that we need to predict the
future five second motion of what the
other merging actor is going to do
and then we call let's say an mpc
planner
that
that computes the optimum trajectory
so
really all we need is a good enough
forecast
of the other actor right
how do we get such forecasts
so the traditional approach in industry
is to treat forecasting
as a cascaded step after perception and
before motion planning
you know recent methods have improved
upon this by joining perception and in
forecasting in a differentiable internet
manner
but crucially still today motion
planning is viewed as a downstream
consumer of forecasts
so let's think through what will happen
as a result of this right
so
let's say we go ahead and collect a lot
of data to train our forecasting model
so in our training data 50 of the time
the human merges after the car and 50 of
the time the human merges before the car
we then train the latest greatest
forecasting model to predict the future
this is what we get right
this forecast looks like it has just
huge it's like a big blob in front of
the truck
right
it has a huge variance
and the planner looks at this freaks out
and says oh my god i have to break to
avoid this blob
um
what happened
the planner was like predicting for like
a worst case scenario
of where like this variance is going to
be like closest to the truck and so it's
trying to avoid the largest distribution
of where it's spread yeah so
yeah so the answer is the planner is
trying to avoid the worst-case scenario
which is great but why does the forecast
look so terrible
the planner is not taking into account
that the human will react to its
behavior yeah okay so you all should
help us um great yeah so
um
as you might have guessed there are two
distinct modes in the data
right um there's mode a where
the
the robot merges after the car and
there's more b where the robot merges
before the car
and when we just train the forecasting
model we marginalize over what the what
the what the robot is doing
right and so we get this distribution
this sort of
marginalizing over these two modes and
then predicting this huge variance
and as a result the planet freaks out
and breaks success excessively
so yeah the key observation as you
pointed out is that
the robot
what the robot does
depends on other humans
but
what humans do depend on the robot
and so
this turns out into turns into a chicken
or egg problem
to
do planning you need forecasts
but to do forecasting you need a
you need the plan you need what the
robot's going to do
so here's an urban example of the robot
taking an unprotected left turn
with vehicles bicyclists and pedestrians
again the same situation that we saw
before comes up where
you know the robot's motion depends on
what the actor turning right is going to
do the actor turning right is looking at
other pedestrians and this oncoming car
that's not sure what we're going to do
so this is
huge complex
dependencies that that involve the robot
in the middle
so
so i guess the the the observation is
that all actors in a scene influence
each other
and the robot is simply an actor that we
get to control but there are other
humans in the scene
so
in some sense as you might have intuited
we need to jointly reason over all the
actors
to forecast them as well as
subsequently um computer plan
right
but wait
the space of joint trajectories
is pretty big like think of a single
trajectory that's a continuous
sequence of um you know two dimensional
vector of waypoints
now you have n actors so you're talking
about a combinatorial space of
you know futures
and moreover this still is not
addressing our chicken or egg problem
right
unless you want to forecast the the the
planner which is a different discussion
so
so our key insight is
that that made this problem tractable
is that it's actually misleading to
think of a continuous space
there's actually an underlying discrete
grammar that we are reasoning about and
we call these grammar
modes um
so it's pretty simple
there are three fundamental modes
you know given two actors you look at
their forecasts and you say
either you know either either they're
going to have some conflict and if if so
somebody goes first or they're not going
to have any conflict so a used to b b
used to a or a and b just don't yield
each other
and
it turns out
and this has worked with mccall at
aurora that pretty much all of
self-driving can be described using this
fundamental discrete grammar you know so
for instance uh take this merging
scenario that we looked at before
you can say something like you can
describe the scenario really well by
saying you know the robot r
used to a
and
this actor b used to r let's say i knew
these i knew this is the mode that we
want the future to be in
um
if we know this knowing this mode we can
actually forecast all three actors
and
and and a single mode corresponds to a
single basin of forecasts so
you know more generally if you were to
write down the value function for all
three actors
that value function is multi-modal but
um
specifying the modes
saying r used to a and b goes to r
specifies a single mode of that holy
function
right and this works for more
complicated scenes as well so let's say
we are lane changing simultaneously with
other actors
knowing the mode
defines the slot that the robot gets
into
and um so
you know
in fact the forecasts need only be
accurate enough for the robot to safely
and predictably get into that slot
okay so how do we
infer what modes various actors are
likely to choose based on choices by the
robot
so let's look at the scene before
and let's abstract it away with a graph
right
imagine each actor as a node in the
graph the edges of the graph tell us
relationships like is actor a yielding
to actor b
so given a set of decisions made by the
robot or modes chosen by the robot
we are going to infer what
um what modes other actors likely are
choosing
and we're going to do this by passing
messages so
for instance we can look at the scene
and say that
um you know the actor turning right
wants to yield to the both the
pedestrians and as a result the robot
must yield to this actor
and finally the oncoming car um
is actually turning left and so
it'll likely not conflict with the robot
so they should both not yield to each
other
and the nice thing is once you've
figured out this mode
you can forecast each actor
independently given modes
and once you have the forecast you can
go ahead and call your favorite mpc
algorithm to get a plan
so
the way we
generate this is by um you know
we we uh put this together
using a multi-stage graph neural network
which we call geometric transformer net
so the transformer here refers to the
aggregation step in the graph neural
network
the high level idea is that you have a
graph neural network where the input
are node features state and history of
each actor
and edge features
transforming one actor to another frame
we then
encode these features and do k rounds of
message passing
and then there are two outputs
um
what is the mode that each edge
corresponds to and then predicting
t-step futures for each actor in the
scene
so
um
yeah and and and so when you put
everything together this is how the
scene kind of plays out
you know we can see that by reasoning
about different modes the robot's able
to kind of confidently go through this
intersection
it's also interesting in the scene you
see our cyclists suddenly pop out from
an occlusion
and and that means that this inference
has to be running rapidly in real time
because it has to detect the sector
figure out what mode it belongs to and
then forecast its future within 10 hertz
right
okay
um
questions yeah
is there a reason that there's no mode
for yield yield when both yield to each
other and kind of get in a standstill
yeah yeah that's a that's a great
question um
we often don't
um
you know we we're we're often at least
at this point we're not modeling places
like eel deal where two actors come to a
stop because they're not able to
communicate
where i think
we're trying to you know the way we
think about
the scene is that you know there's a
flow of traffic and for for that reason
eventually the modes resolve themselves
and and and falls into one of the two
basins where one actor goes and the
other actor stops
uh
but uh yeah certainly you can have
intermediate states where you
where you know two actors both might be
stopping to each other for example at
all way stops but right now we don't
model it
you're modeling are they sort of
described by human engineers deciding
what these modes are or are you
extracting that somehow from a bigger
trajectory forecasting distribution yeah
so we have data i think the way we
extract the mods is
you look at 10 second future then you
you have an auto labeler that figures
out what happened what mode was followed
and then that's used as a source of
label
so i think if you have a complicated
scene and maybe you observe it 10 times
let's say maybe it will not always be
the same set of modes but maybe there's
like two kind of possibilities how it
ends up right yeah it looks to me at
least that this specific architecture
can only ever predict one mode right so
do you think there's any work on an
architecture outputting
multiple sets of modes with maybe some
kind of probability yeah so actually
what i said is the architecture outputs
a probability for each edge of yielding
reverse yielding or ailing to be or
building to a
um so there is a pairwise independence
uh
joint distribution that it's modeling
but you're right um
we're you know
you it can happen that you need to
capture multiple possible interactions
that can play out and then that's some
active work that's what's going on but
uh just doing this gets you a lot of
mileage so
yeah
i think we're running out of time so i'm
just going to skip to the end
unfortunately this is you know
there's a lot of cool videos of this
sort of you know intent prediction
working across various scenes
um i just want to end
quickly to go back to the picture we
laid out initially
um so looking forward so i talked a lot
about self-driving but in my lab at
cornell i'm going to be going back to
personal robots
and i want to bring some of these
insights from self-driving back into
personal robot space space which i think
is far more challenging and far more
open-ended
um but to talk about you know some of
the
directions that i'm interested in so we
talked about learning from natural human
interactions i think
you know in the personal robot space
there's just a lot of questions for
example what are good task
representations for future learning how
do we learn from multimodal feedback
you know learning with
causal confounds like trust and
adaptation
and i think
you know having some answers to these
questions is super critical for personal
robots
um
and for the second challenge planning
alongside human partners and we talked
about discrete modes for self-driving
that was easy what's what are modes when
two humans are you know used doing whole
body manipulation near each other i
don't know
uh how do how do we communicate intent
to collapse uncertainty
um how can robots plan safe predictable
motions
so
you know um
yeah i look forward to tackling some of
these challenges in my lab and lastly i
would like to acknowledge the amazing
co-authors and collaborators in the work
i presented today particularly i would
like to acknowledge the entire team at
aurora you know who worked tirelessly to
make the amazing product we have today
with that
i have to take questions
thanks so much for the great talk
um in that last slide you kind of talked
about future directions for these
personal planners is there um
in your lab and your research going
forward are you looking to try and
dabble in all of those fields or is
there anything in particular that you
that interests you that you're looking
to work towards
yeah that's um so yeah these challenges
are very open-ended i think right now um
my focus is still very much limitation
learning particularly right now we're
looking at causal compounds uh because
it's a problem in self-driving and i
think i suspect it's a problem in any
any robotics where humans have a lot of
leading variables that's what i'm
focusing on now
one of the things i would like to start
with as i move from self-driving to
mobile manipulators is
representations representations and
self-driving a little bit
community has thought about it for a
long time but for manipulation i think
how we represent modes is
pretty challenging but it's key if we
want robots to work
in seamlessly alongside humans i think
that that's that's the thing that will
probably start with
maybe yeah sorry
so if you're focusing on um natural
human interactions
um like a lot of what we learn
um
like let's say you're on the road and
driving a lot of the interactions like
someone in a car and someone in another
car or similar to what we see in just
like normal
non-driving interactions would you take
any of the
like models you develop or what you
learn from natural human interactions
and apply that back to the self-driving
field at all or yeah that's a good
question so the the for self-driving
ultimately um you only need to model
enough for so your product drives like a
human it doesn't necessarily need to
have
the nuance it turns out from after years
of looking at this we the nuance with
which you and i might you know
infer how the scene evolves like
someone's you know doing road rage the
robot doesn't need to infer to that
granularity so
you can get to a product without getting
you know inferring to that level i'm
pretty sure that's not the case for
personal robots perhaps
because just because they're
they're interacting much more up close
with humans so probably not in
self-driving probably it'll go the other
way
where you try to take some of these
insights and try to simplify the
personal robots problem and see
where to go from there
yeah
and
robots like also reason about kind of
the perception that other actors in the
road have for example if you're
following a car and you see that
suddenly it swerves out of its lane or
slows down then you could infer that
there's an obstacle before you can see
it but is there a way that it could do
something like that yeah and and that
happens a lot for example construction
sometimes you don't see construction but
the robot's reasoning and and we are
actually working on that in our model at
the moment you know you can infer that
you can infer based on the emotions that
there's some object there that's
correlating what all the actors are
doing they're all certainly laying
changing so that's something that we're
modeling at the moment
um
in self-driving data sets
coming across situations where something
dangerous happens or when an accident
happens is really really rare
when you train these models do you do
anything like upsampling
situations that you deem to be dangerous
to make sure that your model is accurate
and very very rare situation yeah
excellent question
that's right if you take you you have to
uh you you can't simply do empirical
risk minimization because 99 is boring
you have to you know create clusters of
data points that you know and make sure
your model is good across the board the
second thing i want to say is that um if
events you know events happen rarely
because humans are really good at
guarding against events and they get out
of situations and so that's really a key
thing the robots have to learn how to
guard like humans so they don't get into
those trouble situations i think that's
the key piece that that that makes the
product possible
with that i want to thank you again for
coming in person to give a talk at the
samsung robotics webinar they do it
again yeah thank you everyone